dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Pierre Charon
pour le groupe UMP
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues comme la rappeler
ministre à l'instant dans sa décision du
16 mai 2013 le Conseil constitutionnel a
censuré la nouvelle répartition des
conseillers de Paris prévus par le
projet de Loire relatif à l'élection des
conseillers départementaux des
conseillers municipaux et des
conseillers communautaires le groupe UMP
associé à l'UDA
avait effectivement ses îles conseils
constitutionnel au motifs que la
répartition proposée par le gouvernement
ne respectait pas la règle élémentaire
de la démocratie représentative un homme
une voix
en effet trois arrondissements étaient
sanctionnés ces choses dire trois
arrondissements dit de droite septième
du septième 16e au profit
d'arrondissement dit de gauche nous
avons été entendus comme la rappeler le
président sueur et un peu au-delà de nos
espérances
c'est vrai
ce dernier est même allé encore plus
loin donc en décla rencontres à la
concession l'actuel tableau de
répartition des conseillers de Paris un
excès au code électoral ce chamboulement
était certes imprévu président sueur
mais nous disait quelque chose de
fondamental de l'organisation électorale
de la capitale dès lors il fait les
trouver une solution qui permet
d'organiser le prochain scrutin dans le
souci de respecter les institutions et
la démocratie plusieurs choix étaient
envisageables
celui qui nous est présenté aujourd'hui
n'est malheureusement pas celui qui me
semble le plus adapté à la situation
parisienne nous avons tous fait tourner
les ordinateurs pour calculer toutes les
répartitions possibles je dénombre au
moins quatre systèmes respectant
purement la démographie qui aurait pu
être utilisé et qui aurait chacun donné
une répartition différente même en se
retranchant derrière la démographie nous
voyons qu'il y a nécessairement de la
partialité
oui nous pourrions par exemple en tenir
le cas du 17e arrondissement qui dans
les deux dernières propositions gagne
des habitants mais perd un élu c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'avais rencontré
le Premier ministre pour lui proposer
une intervention à minima et j'ai trouvé
quelqu'un de très réceptif
très réceptif c'est à l'époque que
c'était matillons qui s'occupait du
problème
étant donné qu'aucun tableau ne peut
être incontestable et étant donné que
nous sommes maintenant à moins de 8 mois
de l'élection municipale il m'avait
semblé juste de toucher le moins
possible ce tableau avant d'envisager
pour l'élection prochaine une refonte
plus importante du système sur des bases
que j'aimerais évoquer avec vous
aujourd'hui
avec cette intervention à minima plutôt
que de revoir toute la grille de
répartition vous auriez pu vous
contenter d'enlever des sièges là où
c'était nécessaire pour entrer dans le
tunnel des 20% et non ajouter que là où
cela a été arithmétiquement nécessaire
afin qu'un arrondissement plus peuplé ne
puisse pas avoir moins de siège ce
système minimaliste aurait limité les
pertes aux arrondissements 1 2 4 7 et
aurait donné un siège supplémentaire au
19e arrondissement
vous auriez dû saisir cette proposition
qui avait le mérite de changer le moins
de choses possible pour 2014 tout en se
confortant rigoureusement aux
recommandations du Conseil
constitutionnel au lieu de cela vous
avez persévéré dans l'arbitraire mes
chers collègues les héritages électoraux
ont souvent du sens il faut alors les
respecter en revanche certains
dispositifs sont irrités d'un autre âge
et peuvent se trouver en décalage
complet avec la réalité d'un territoire
et de sa représentation il me semble que
c'est bien le cas de l'élection du maire
de Paris je vous rappelle que les
électeurs parisiens sont les seuls avec
ceux de lions et Marseille à élire leur
mère au suffrage universel indirect à 2
degrés à l'heure du Grand Paris cette
particularité électorale est devenue une
égalité inégalité démocratique
nous avons aujourd'hui l'occasion non
seulement de rebattre les cartes de
l'organisation électorale parisienne
mais de les redistribuer de façon
équitable généreuse et moderne toutes
les voies des parisiennes et des
Parisiens se valent le découpage par
arrondissement qui doit bien entendu
permettre l'élection d'un maire et d'un
conseil d'arrondissement ne doit pas
être une entrave à l'élection du maire
de la capitale et du Conseil de Paris
qui doit se faire dans la transparence
du suffrage universel direct je défends
cette idée depuis plusieurs années
maintenant et je crois que cette
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
devrait être l'occasion de mener cette
réforme incontournable de la carte
électorale parisienne une des raisons de
cette amélioration de la situation
parisienne est la mobilité toujours
croissante des Parisiens cette mobilité
qui est une chance pour notre capital en
termes de brassage de diversité sociale
et générationnel nous doit pas être figé
dans sa représentation élective cette
rigidité tout à fait artificielle
entraîne d'ailleurs des ajustements
réguliers quand les mouvements de
population rendent les distorsions trop
importantes mes chers collègues nous
savons tous qu'au gré des majorités des
ajustements de répartition sont souvent
l'occasion de bricolage qui servent les
uns et desservent les autres nous avons
aujourd'hui la possibilité d'en finir
avec ces calculs qui nuisent à la vie
politique et qui brouille la lisibilité
de l'organisation électorale parisienne
pourquoi valider un tableau qui sera
mécaniquement caduque dès l'année
prochaine quand nous pouvons offrir aux
Parisiens et aux Parisiens délirent
directement leur mère et ainsi s'aligner
avec toutes les grandes capitales du
monde pourquoi s'entêter dans un système
qui déclenche toujours querelles et
désaccords que nous pourrions poser la
capitale soit des bases solides du
suffrage universel direct pourquoi
persister dans un système alambiqué
quand l'heure est je
à la transparence politique
dois-je rappeler que le système auquel
vous vous accrochez aujourd'hui cette
incongruité électorale devrais-je dire a
permis à Bertrand Delanoë d’être élu
avec 49% des suffrages en 2001 et
qu'avec moins de voix que la droite la
gauche a obtenu 21 sièges d'avance au
Conseil de Paris ce n'était pas
d'ailleurs une nouveauté Gaston de fer
l'homme qui a inventé la loi PLM avait
déjà bénéficié de cette entourloupe
électorale en 83 quand il fut réélu à la
mairie de Marseille alors que
Jean-Claude Gaudin avait obtenu plus de
suffrages que lui sur l'ensemble de la
commune
je ne parle pas de Lyon monsieur le
ministre j'ai particulièrement étudié
l'exposé les motifs justifiant les vases
communicants opérés sur le tableau qui
est à lui seul le meilleur plaidoyer
pour un changement radical du système je
dis ça sans aucune ironie et j'admire la
virtuosité du président sueur et avec
lui du président urvoise mais il vous
conviendrez avec moi que les calculs de
pondération
virent parfois à la contorsion
je vous le reproche pas d'ailleurs car
c'est tout simplement un héron à la
forme même de la sectorisation du corps
électoral du Conseil de Paris c'est
pourquoi je regrette que vous n'ayez pas
profité de cette belle occasion donnée
par le Conseil constitutionnel pour
tourner la page des rafistolages et pour
offrir à Paris une élection sans calcul
et sans détour ce serait également
l'occasion de libérer Paris des logiques
politiciens qui sont malheureusement
encouragés par l'organisation par
arrondissement sans quoi nous savons
toutes et tous ici que nous devrons à
nouveau occuper cette hémicycle à
l'occasion de la prochaine révision du
tableau pour batailler sur des plus
simples par ici et des moins impars je
ne suis pas sûr que notre eau assemblée
grandisse de ses calculs dépiciers
l'expression de la démocratie qui est
l'élection suffrage universel mérite
plus de clarté de générosité c'est
pourquoi mes chers collègues je ne
voterai pas ce texte qui reste un
bricolage de plus à l'heure où nous
devrions faire preuve d'audace
d'innovation de simplicité je vous
remercie